[Music]
welcome to Carnegie Mellon online for
more multimedia from Carnegie Mellon
University visit WWE
thank you that's very kind but never tip
the waiter before the meal arrives it's
a thank-you Gabe and Jim I couldn't
imagine being more grateful for an
introduction these are two people that
I've known a long long time I taught
here at the University of Virginia I
love this school it's just an incredible
place filled with tradition and history
and respect the kind of qualities that I
really admire that I want to see
preserved in American society and this
is one of the places that I just love
for preserving that I think the honor
code alone at the University of Virginia
just is something that every University
administrator should study and look at
and say you know why can't we do that
too so I think there are a lot of things
about this place to love I'm going to
talk today on the topic of time
management the circumstances are as you
probably know a little bit unusual I
think at this point I'm an authority to
talk about what to do with limited time
my my battle with pancreatic cancer
started about a year and a half ago
thought did all the right things but
it's you know as my oncologist said if
you could pick off a list that's not the
one you'd want to pick so on August 15th
these were my cat scans you can see that
if you scroll through all of them there
were about a dozen tumors in my liver
and the doctors at that time said you
are likely to have three - I love the
way they say it you have three to six
months of good health
left right optimism and positive
phrasing it's sort of like when you're a
Disney what time does the park closed
the park is open until 8:00
so I have three to six months of good
health well let's do the math today is
three months and 12 days so what I had
on my day timer for today was not
necessarily being at the University of
Virginia
I'm pleased to say that we do treat with
palliative chemo they're going to buy me
a little bit of time on the order of a
few months if it continues to work I am
still in perfectly good health with Gabe
of the audience I'm not going to do
push-ups because I'm not going to be
shown up Gabe is really in good shape
but I to be in relatively good health I
had chemotherapy yesterday you should
all try it great but it does sort of beg
the question I have finite time some
people said you know so why are you
going and giving a talk well there a lot
of reasons I'm coming here and giving a
talk one of them is that I said I would
write that's a pretty simple reason and
I'm physically able to another one is
that going to the University of Virginia
is not like going to some far in place
people say aren't you spending all your
time with family and by coming back here
for a day I am spending my time with
family both metaphorically and literally
because it turns out that many of you
have probably seen this picture from the
talk that I gave these are my niece and
nephew Chris and Laura and my niece
Laura is actually a senior a fourth year
here at mr. Jefferson's University so
Laura could you stand up so they see
what you've gotten taller there we go
and I I couldn't be happier to have her
here at this university and the other
the other person so that's Laura the
other person in this picture is Chris
and Chris if you could stand up so they
say you've got much taller and they have
grown in so many ways not just in height
and it's been wonderful to see that and
be an uncle to them is there anybody
here on the faculty or PhD students of
the history department we have any
history people here at all okay anybody
hears from history find Chris right
after the talk because he's currently in
his sophomore year at William and Mary
and he's interested in going into a ph.d
program in history down the road and
there aren't many better PhD programs in
history than this one so so I'm pimping
for my nephew here let's be clear all
right so what are we going to talk about
today we're going to talk about you know
this is not like the lecture that you
may have seen me give before this is a
very pragmatic lecture and one of the
reasons that I had agreed to come back
and give this is because Gabe had told
me that and many other faculty Mears had
told me that they had gotten so much
tangible value about how to get more
done and I truly do believe that time is
the only commodity that matters so this
is a very pragmatic talk and it is
inspirational in a sense it will inspire
you by giving you some concrete things
you might do to be able to get more time
more things done in your finite time so
I'm going to talk specifically about how
to set goals how to avoid wasting time
how to deal with a boss originally this
talk was about how to deal with your
advisor but I've tried to broaden it so
it's not quite so academically focused
and how to delegate to people some
specific skills and tools that I might
recommend to help you get more out of
the day and to deal with the real
problems in our life which are stress
and procrastination I mean if you can
lick that last one you're probably in
good shape and really you don't need to
take any notes so I'll presume if I see
any laptops open you're actually just
you know doing I am or email or
something if you're listening to music
please at least wear headphones I would
always say but all of this will be
posted on my website and just to make it
really easy
if you want to know when to look up any
slides that have a red star on them are
the points that I think you should
really make sure that you you got that
one and conversely if it doesn't have a
red star well so the first thing I want
to say is that Americans are very very
bad at dealing with time as a commodity
we're really good at dealing with money
as a commodity
I mean we're as a culture very
interested in money and how much
somebody earns is a status thing and so
on and so forth but we don't really have
time elevated to that people waste their
time and just always fascinates me and
one of things that I noticed is that
very few people equate time and money
and they're very very equatable so the
first thing I started doing when I was a
teacher was asking my graduate students
well how much is your time worth an hour
or if you work at a company how much is
your time worth to the company what most
people don't realize is that if you have
a salary let's say you make $50,000 a
year it probably costs that company
twice that in order to have you as an
employee because there's heating and
lighting and other staff members on so
forth so if you get paid $50,000 a year
you are costing that company they may
have to raise $100,000 in revenue and if
you divide that by your hourly rate you
begin to get some sense of what you are
worth an hour and when you have to make
trade-offs of should I do something like
write software or should I just buy it
or should I outsource this having in
your head what you cost your
organization an hour is really kind of a
staggering thing to change your behavior
because you start realizing that wow if
I free up 3 hours of my time and I'm
thinking of that in terms of dollars
that's a big savings so start thinking
about your time and your money almost as
if they are the same thing
and of course Ben Franklin knew that a
long time ago so you've got to manage it
and you've got to manage it just like
you manage your money now I realize not
all Americans manage their money that's
what makes the credit card industry
possible and that's and apparently
mortgages too so but most people do at
least understand they don't look at you
funny if you say well can I see your
monetary budget for your household in
fact if I say your household budget you
presume that I'm talking about money
when in fact the household budget I
really want to
about is probably your household time
budget the other team and Technology
Center at Carnegie Mellon students would
come in and during the orientation I
would say this is a master's program
everybody's paying full tuition and it
was roughly thirty thousand dollars a
year and the first thing I would say is
if you're going to come into my office
and say I don't think this is worth
$60,000 a year I will throw you out of
the office I'm not even going to have
that discussion and of course they would
say oh god this couch guy is a real jerk
and then they were right but what I then
followed on with was because the money
is not important you can go and earn
more money later and what you'll never
do is get to two years of your life back
so if you want to come into my office
and talk about the money I'll throw you
out but if you want to come into my
office and say I'm not sure this is a
good place for me to spend two years I
will talk to you all day and all night
because that means we're talking about
the right thing which is your time
because you can't ever get it back a lot
of the advice I'm going to give you
particularly for undergraduates how many
people in this in this room are
undergraduates by show of hands okay
good
still young a lot of this would've done
Hans and Franz and start night live if
you're old enough hear me now but
believe me later right a lot of this is
going to make sense later and one of
nice things as I gave gaybies
volunteered to put this up on the web I
understand that people can actually
watch videos on the web now services so
a lot of this only makes sense later and
when I talk about your boss if you're a
student think about that is your
academic advisor if you're a PhD student
thing about is your PhD advisor and if
you're you know if you're watching this
and you're a young child think of this
as your parent because that's sort of
the person who is in some sense your
boss and the talk goes very fast and I
as I said I'm very big on specific
techniques I'm not really big on
platitudes
I mean platitudes are nice but they
don't really help me get something done
tomorrow the other thing is that one
good thief is worth 10 good scholars and
in fact you can replace the word
scholars in that sentence with almost
anything so almost everything in this
talk is to some degree inspired which is
a fancy fancy way of saying lifted four
from these two books and I found those
books very useful but it's much better
to get them into distilled form so what
I'm basically done is
is collected the nuggets for your bath I
like to talk about the time famine I
think it's a nice phrase does anybody
here feel like they have too much time
okay
nobody excellent and I like the word
famine because it's a little bit like
thinking about Africa I mean you can
airlift all the foods you want in to
solve the crisis this week but the
problem is systemic and you really need
systemic solutions so a time management
solution that says oh I'm going to fix
things for you in the next 24 hours is
laughable just like saying I'm going to
cure hunger in Africa in the next year
you need to think long term and you need
to change fundamental underlying
processes because the problem is
systemic we just have too many things to
do and not enough time to do them the
other thing to remember is it's not just
about time management that sounds like a
kind of a lukewarm you know a talk on
time management that's kind of you know
milquetoast but how about if the talk is
how about not having ulcers right that
catches my attention so a lot of this is
life advice this is how to change the
way you're doing a lot of the things and
how you allocate your time so that you
will lead a happier more wonderful life
and I loved in the introduction that you
talked about fun because if I've brought
fun to academia well it's about damn
time I mean you know if you're not going
to have fun why do it right that's what
I want to know I mean life really is too
short if you're not going to enjoy it
you know people who say well I'm I've
got a job and I don't really like it and
I'm like well you could change oh that
would be a lot of work you're right you
should keep going to work everyday doing
a job you don't like thank you a good
night right so the overall goal is fun
my middle child Logan is is my favorite
example I don't think he knows how to
not have fun now grant a lot of things
he does are not fun for his mother and
me but he's loving every second of it
and he doesn't know how to do anything
that isn't ballistic and full of life
and he's going to keep that quality I
think he's my little Tigger and I always
remember Logan when I think about the
goal is to make sure that you lead your
life you know I want to maximize use of
time but really that's the means not the
end the end is maximizing fun people who
do intense studies
and long people and videotape and so on
and so forth say that the typical office
worker wastes almost two hours a day
all right their desk is messy they can't
find things miss appointments unprepared
for meetings they can't concentrate does
anybody in here by show of hands ever
have any sense that one of these things
is part of their life okay I think we've
got everybody so these are the universal
thing and you shouldn't feel guilty if
some of these things are plaguing you
because they plague all of us they
plagued me for sure and the other thing
I want to tell you is that it sounds a
little cliched and trite but being
successful does not make you manage your
time well managing your time well makes
you successful if I have been successful
in my career I assure you it's not
because I'm smarter than all the other
faculty I mean I'm looking around and
looking at some of my former colleagues
I mean I see Jim Cahoon up there I am
not smarter than Jim Cahoon okay you
know I constantly look around the
faculty places like the University of
Virginia or Carnegie Mellon and I go
damn these are smart people and I snuck
in but what I like to think I'm good at
is the meta skills because if you're
going to have to run with people who are
faster than you you have to like find
the right ways to optimize what skills
you do have so let's talk first about
goals priorities and planning anytime
anything crosses your life you've got to
ask this thing I'm thinking about doing
why am i doing it almost no one that I
know starts with the core principle of
there's this thing on my to-do list why
is it there because if you start asking
well why is I mean again my kids are
great at this that's all I ever hear at
home is why why why right and soon early
we're gonna stop saying why they're just
gonna say okay I'll do it right so ask
why am I doing this what is the goal why
will I succeed at doing it and here's my
favorite what will happen if I don't do
it if I just say yeah I'm just not the
best thing in the world and have
something on my to-do list and I just go
no no one has ever come and taken me to
jail I talked my way out of a speeding
ticket last week it's really cool
it's like the closest I'm ever going to
be to attractive and blonde I told the
guy you know why we had just moved and
so on and so forth and he looked at me
and he said well for a guy who's only
got a couple of months to live you sure
look good and I just pulled up my shirt
to share the scar and I said yeah I look
good on the outside but the tumors are
on the inside he just ran back to his
cruiser and so that's one positive
law-enforcement experience for me so
yeah so the police have never come
because I cross something off my to-do
list and and that's a very powerful
thing because you just got all that time
back the other thing to keep in mind
when you're doing goal-setting
is a lot of people focus on doing things
right I think it's very dangerous to
focus on doing things right I think it's
much more important to do the right
things if you do the right things
adequately that's much more important
than doing the wrong things beautifully
all right doesn't matter how well you
polish the underside of the Bannister
okay and keep that in mind Lou Holtz had
a great list Lou Holtz's 100 things to
do in his life and he would sort of once
a week look at it and say you know if
I'm not working on those 100 things why
was i working on the others and I just
think that's an incredible way to frame
things there's something called the
80/20 rule sometimes you'll hear about
the 90/10 rule but the key thing to
understand is that a very small number
of things in your life or on your to-do
list are going to contribute the vast
majority the veil of the value so if you
have if you're a salesperson 80% of the
revenue is going to come from 20% of
your clients and you better figure out
who those 20% are and spend all of your
time sucking up to them because that's
where the revenue comes so you've got to
really be willing to say this stuff is
what's going to be the value and this
other stuff isn't and you've gotta have
the courage of your convictions to say
and therefore I'm going to shove the
other stuff off of the boat the other
thing you can remember is that
experience comes with time and it's
really really valuable and there are no
shortcuts to getting it so good judgment
comes from experience and experience
comes from bad judgment
so if things aren't going well that
probably means you're learning a lot and
it'll go better later this is by the way
why we pay so much in American Society
for people who are you know typically
older but have done lots of things in
their past because we're paying for
their experience because we know that
experience is one of the things you
can't fake and do not lose the sight do
not lose sight of the power of
inspiration so Randy's in a in an hour
long talk and you know we've already get
our first Disney reference Walt Disney's
quote well does he has many great quotes
what I love is if you can dream it you
can do it and a lot of my cynical
friends say yada yada yada to which I
say shut up all right
inspiration is important and I'll tell
you this much if you I don't know if
Walt was right but I'll tell you this
much if you refuse to allow yourself to
dream it I know you won't do it so the
power of dreams are that they give us a
way to take the first step towards an
accomplishment and Walt was also not
just a dreamer Hult worked really hard
Disneyland this amazes me because I know
a little bit about how hard it is to put
theme park attractions together and they
did the whole original Disneyland Park
in 366 days that's from the first shovel
full of dirt to the first paid admission
right think about how long it takes to
do something say at a State University
by comparison so it's a you know it's
just fascinating when someone once asked
Walt Disney how did you get it done in
366 days he just deadpan we used every
one of them so again there are no short
carts certain short cuts there's a lot
of hard work and anything you want to
accomplish planning is very important
one of the time management cliches is
planning to fail failing to plan is
planning to fail and planning has to be
done at multiple levels I have a plan
every morning when I wake up and I say
what do I need to get done today what I
need to get done this week what do I
need to get done each semester that's
third of the time quanta because I'm an
academic and that doesn't mean you're
locked into it people say yeah but
things are so fluid you know I'm going
to have to change the plan and I'm like
yes you are going to have to change the
plan but you can't change it unless you
have it and the excuse of I'm not going
to make a plan because things might
change is just this paralysis of I don't
have any marching orders so have a plan
acknowledge that you're going to change
it but have it so you have the basis to
start with to-do lists how many people
here right now if I said can you produce
it could show me their to-do list okay
not bad not bad the key thing with to-do
lists is you have to break things down
into small steps I literally once I
might to do this when I was a junior
faculty member at the University of
Virginia
I put get tenure that that was naive and
I looked at that for a while and I said
oh that's really hard I don't think I
can do that and my children Dylan and
Logan and Chloe particularly Dylan is at
the age where he can clean his own Dan
room thank you very much but he doesn't
like to and Chris is smiling because I
used to do this story on him but now I
cut my own kids to pick on but Dylan
will come to me and say I can't pick up
my room it's too much stuff he's not
even a teenager and he's already got
that movie yeah and I say well can you
make your bed yeah I can do that okay
can you put all the clothes in the
hamper yeah I can do that
and you know you do three or four things
and then it's like well Dylan you just
cleaned your room I cleaned my room and
he feels good he is empowered and
everybody's happy and of course I've had
to spend twice as much time managing him
as I could have done it by myself but
that's okay that's what being a boss is
about is growing your people no matter
how small or large they might be at the
time the last thing about to-do lists
are getting yourself going is if you've
got a bunch of things to do do the
ugliest thing first there's an old
saying if you have to eat a frog don't
spend a lot of time looking at it first
and if you have to eat three of them
don't start with the small one
all right this is the most important
slide in the entire talk so if you want
to leave after this slide I will not be
offended because it's all downhill from
here and this is blatantly stolen this
is Steven Covey's great contribution to
the world he talks about it and one in
the seven Habits book it's imagine your
to-do list most people sort their to-do
lists either you know the order that I
got it throw it on the bottom or they
sort it in due date list which is more
sophisticated and more helpful but still
very very raw so looking at the four
quadrant to-do list if you've got a
quadrant where things are important
excuse me and ooh soon important and not
due soon not important and due soon and
not important and not due soon all right
which of these four quadrants do you
think upper left upper right lower left
or right which one do you think you
should work on immediately upper left
you are such a great crowd okay and
which one do you think you should
probably do last lower right and that's
you know that's easy that's obviously
number one that's obviously number four
but this is where everybody in my
experience gets it wrong what we do now
is we say I do the number ones and then
I move on to the stuff that's due soon
and not important when you write it in
this quadrant list it's really stunning
because I've actually seen people do
this and they say okay and this is due
soon and I know it's not important I'm
going to get right to work on it and the
most crucial thing I can teach you about
time management is when you're done
picking off the important and do soon
that's when you go here you go - it's
not due soon and it's important and
there will be a moment in your life
where you say hey this thing that's due
soon but not important I won't do it
because it's not important it says so
right here on the chart
and and magically you have time to work
on the thing that is not due soon but is
important so that next week it never got
a chance to get here because you killed
it in the crib my wife won't like that
metaphor but you kill the or you you you
solve the problem of something that's
due next week when you're not under time
stress because it's not due tomorrow and
suddenly you become one of those
zen-like people who just always seem to
have all the time in the world because
they've figured this out alright
paperwork the first thing you need to
know is that having cluttered paperwork
leads to thrashing you end up with all
these things on your desk and you can't
find anything and the moment you turn to
your desk your desk is saying to you I
own you I have more things than you can
do and there are many colors and laid
out so what I find is that it's really
crucial to keep your desk clear and
we'll talk about where all the paper
goes in a second and you have one thing
on your desk because then it's like ha
now it's Thunderdome me and the one
piece of paper right and so I usually
win that one one of the mantras of time
management is touch each piece of paper
once you get the piece of paper you look
at it you you work at it and I think
that's extremely true for email how many
people here well I'm going to take it
for granted that everybody here has an
email inbox how many people right now
have more than 20 items in their email
inbox oh I'm in the right room your
inbox is not your to-do list and I my
wife has learned that I need to get my
inbox clear now sometimes this really
means just filing things away and
putting something on my to-do list
remember the to-do list is sorted by
importance but my eat does anybody here
have an e mop you have an email program
where you can press the sort by
importance button you know it's amazing
how people who build software that
really is a huge part of our life and
getting work done
and a clue and that's not a slam on any
particular company I think they all have
missed the boat and I just find it
fascinating because everybody I know
where most people I know have this inbox
that I got to ask how many people have
more than 100 things in their email I'm
just not going to go and this is too
depressing
so you really want to get the thing in
your inbox look at it and say I mean
they're going to read it right now or
I'm going to file it and put an entry in
my to-do list and and that's just a
crucial thing because otherwise every
time you go to read your email
you're just swamped and it's just as bad
as the cluttered paper you're all trying
to figure out how that heading goes with
that picture a filing system is
absolutely essential and I know this
because I married the most wonderful
woman in the world
but she's not a good filer but she is
now because after we got married and we
moved in together and we resolved all
the other typical couple things I said
we have to have a place where our papers
go and it's in alphabetical order and
she said that sounds a little compulsive
and I said okay honey so I went out to
Ikea and I got this big nice way too
expensive big wooden fake mahogany thing
with big drawers so she liked it because
it looked kind of kind of nice and
having a place in our house where any
piece of paper went and was in
alphabetical order did wonderful things
for our marriage because there was never
any of this honey where did you put blah
blah blah right and there was never
being mad at somebody because they had
put something in someone ex place there
was an expected place for it and when
you're looking for important receipts or
whatever it is this is actually
important and we have found that this
has been a wonderful thing for us I
think filesystems among groups of people
whether it's a marriage or an office are
crucial but even if it's just you having
a place where you know you put something
really beats all hell out of running
around for an hour going where is it I
know it's blue and I was eating
something when I read it I mean this is
this is not a filing system this is
madness a lot of people ask me so Randy
what is your desk look like so as my
wife would say this is what Randy's desk
looks like when he's photographing it
for a talk the important thing is that
I'm a computer geek so I have the desk
off to the right and then I have a
computer station off to the left I like
to have my desk in front of a window
whenever I can do that this is an old
photograph these have now been replaced
by LCD monitors but I left the old
picture because the crucial thing is it
doesn't matter if they're fancy
high-tech the key thing is screen space
lots of people have studied this how
many people in this room have more than
one monitor on their computer desktop
okay not bad so we're getting there it's
starting to happen what I found is that
I could go back from three to two but I
just can't go back to one there's just
too many things and if somebody said
it's the difference between working on a
desk like at home and trying to get work
done on the little tray on an airplane
in principle the little tray on the
airplane is big enough for everything
you need to do it's just that in
practice it's it's pretty small so
multiple monitors I think are very
important and I'll show you in a second
what I have on each one of those and I
believe in this multiple monitor thing
we believed in it for
long time that's that's my research
group our our laboratory a long time ago
Carnegie Mellon that's Caitlin Kelleher
who's now dr. Kelleher thank you and
she's at Washington University in st.
Louis doing doing wonderful things but
we we had everybody with three monitors
and the cost on this is absolutely
trivial if you figure the cost of adding
a second monitor to an employee's yearly
cost of the company it's not even 1%
anymore so why would you not do it so
one of my walk aways for all of you is
you should all go to your boss and say I
need a second monitor I just can't work
without it Randy told me to tell you
that because it will increase your
productivity and the computers can all
drive two monitors so why not so what do
I have on my three monitors on the left
is my to-do list all sorts of stuff in
there and my system we're all
idiosyncratic my system is that I just
put a number zero through nine and I use
an editor that can quickly sort on that
number in the first column but the key
thing is it's sorted by priority in the
middle is my mail program note the empty
inbox and I try very hard I sleep better
if I go to sleep with the inbox empty
when my inbox does creep up I get really
testy so my wife will actually say to me
I think you need to clear the inbox
on the third one is a calendar that's
this is from a number of years ago but
that's kind of like what my my my days
would be I used to be very heavily
booked and I don't care which software
you use it on which care which calendars
I don't care if it's paper or computer
whatever works for you but you should
have some system whereby you know where
you're supposed to be next Tuesday at 2
o'clock because even if you can live
your life without that you're using up a
lot of your brain to remember all that
and I don't know about you but I don't
have enough brain to spare to use it on
things I can have paper or computers do
for me so back to the overview on the
desk itself let's zoom in a little bit
look I have the one and one thing I'm
working on at the time I have a
speakerphone
this is crucial how many people here
have a speakerphone on their desks ok
not bad but a lot more people don't
speaker phones are essentially free and
I spend a lot of time on hold and that's
because I live in American society where
I get to listen to messages of the forum
your call is extremely important to us
watch while my actions are cognitively
dissonant from my words
you know it's like the worst abusive
relationship in the world
I mean imagine a guy picks you up on the
first day and he smacks you in the mouth
and says I love you honey
that's that's pretty much how modern
customer service works on the telephone
but the great thing about a speakerphone
is you hit the speakerphone and you dial
and then you just do something else and
if it takes seven minutes it takes seven
minutes and hey I just look at this as
somebody's piping music into my office
that's very nice of them I also found
that having a timer on the clock on the
on the phone is handy so that when
somebody finally picks up in Bangalore I
can I I can say things like I'm so glad
to be talking with you by the way if
you're keeping records on this sort of
thing I've been on hold for seven and
half minutes but you don't say it angry
you just say it as I presume you're
logging this kind of stuff and you're
not angry so they don't get angry back
at you but they feel really guilty and
that's good you want guilty right so a
speakerphone is really great I find that
a speakerphone is probably the best
material possession you can buy to
counter stress if I were like teaching a
yoga and meditation class I'd say we'll
do all the yoga meditation I think
that's wonderful stuff but everybody
also has to have a speakerphone what
else do we have besides a speakerphone
let's talk about telephones for a second
I think that the telephone is a great
time-waster and I think it's very
important to keep your business calls
short so I recommend standing during
phone calls great for exercise and if
you tell yourself I'm not going to sit
down until the call is over you'll be
amazed how much brisker you are start by
announcing goals for the call hello sue
this is Randy I'm calling you because I
have three things that I want to get
done boom boom boom
because then you've given her an agenda
and when you're done with the three
things you can say that's great those
are the three things I had it was great
to talk to you I love to talk to you
again bye boom we're off the phone
whatever you do do not put your feet up
I mean if you put the feet up it's just
all over and the other handy trick is
have something on your desk that you
actually are kind of interested in going
to do next
so the phone call instead of being wow I
can get off the phone and go do some
work or I could keep chit-chatting and
usually the person you've called they'd
like to chitchat too
all right so this is where the time
waster in the office goes and if you're
a grad student well if you're a grad
student already know about time wasting
so having something you really want to
do next is a great way to get you off
the phone quicker so you got to train
yourself getting off the phone is hard
for a lot of people I don't suffer from
an abundance of politeness so my sister
who's known me for a long time is
laughing a knowing laugh so when I want
to get off the phone I want to get off
the phone I'm done and what I say is you
know I love to keep talking with you but
I have some students waiting now I'm a
professor somewhere there must be
students waiting right I mean it's got
to be now sometimes you get in a
situation like with a telemarketer all
right and that's awkward because a lot
of people are so polite I have no
trouble with telemarketers I'll just go
there with them and if you're a
telemarketer and you call my house you
have made a mistake yeah I can't talk
right now but once you give me your home
phone number and I'll call you back
around dinnertime Seinfeld did a great
bit on that or or if you want to be a
little bit more over the line I'd love
to talk with you about that but first I
have some things I'd like to sell you
and the funny part is they never realize
you're yanking with them that's but if
you have to hang up on a telemarketer
what you do is you hang up while you're
talking well I think that's really
interesting and I would love to keep
I mean talk about self-effacing hanging
up on yourself and they won't figure it
out if they do and they call back just
don't answer right so a ten years from
now all anybody will remember from this
talk is hang up on yourself the other
thing is group your phone calls call
people right before lunch or right
before the end of the day because then
they have something they would rather do
than keep shitty chatting with you so I
find that calling somebody at 11:50 is a
great way to have a ten-minute phone
call because frankly you may think
you're interesting but you are not more
interesting than lunch I have become
very obsessive about phones and using
time productively so I I just think that
everybody should have something like
this I don't care about fashion so you
know I don't have Bluetooth and you know
I have this big ugly thing hi I'm Julie
from time-life right but the thing this
allows me to do because you know I am
sort of living the limit case right now
I've I've got to get stuff done and I
really don't have a lot of time so I get
an hour a day where I exercise on my
bike and this is me on my bike and if
you look carefully you can see I'm
wearing that headset I've got my cell
phone and for an hour a day I ride my
bike around the neighborhood this is
time that I'm spending on the phone
getting work done and it's not a moment
being taken away from my wife or my
children and it turns out that I can
talk and ride a bike at the same time
amazing the skill sets I have so it
works better in cold weather climate in
warm weather climates but I have just
found that having a headset frees me up
even it's just around the house you wear
a headset you can fold laundry it's an
absolute twofer and I just think
telephones should have headsets and
someday we will all have the Borg
implant and it will be a non-issue what
else is on my desk I have sort of one of
those address stampers because I got
tired of writing my address I have a box
of Kleenex in your box at work if you're
a faculty member you have to have a box
of Kleenex because it
Jim is laughing right you know at least
if you teach the way I do
there will be crying students in your
office and what I found to diffuse a lot
of that is that I would have cs3 52 or
whatever written on the side of the
Kleenex box and I would turn it as I
handed it to them and they would take
the Kleenex and it would be like oh I
said yeah yeah you know it's for the
class you're not alone so having Kleenex
is very important and thank-you cards
I'll now ask the embarrassment question
and I don't mean to pick on you but it
just points things out so well by show
of hands who here has written a
thank-you note that is not a quid pro
quo I don't mean oh you gave me a gift I
wrote you a thank-you note and I mean a
physical thank-you note with a pen and
ink and paper not not email because
email is better than nothing but it's
that much better than nothing okay how
many people here have written a
thank-you note in the last week not bad
I do better here than at most places
because it is UVA chivalry is not dead
but that's how many people in the last
month how many people in the last year
the fact that there are a non-trivial
number of hands not up for the year
means that anybody who's in this
audience as parents are going that was
my kid thank you notes are really
important there they're a very tangible
way to tell someone how much you
appreciated things I have thank you
notes with me and that's because I'm
actually writing some later today to
some people who've done some nice things
for me recently and you say well God you
have time for that I'm like yes I have
time for that because it's important
even in my current status I will make
time to write thank-you notes to people
and even if you're a crafty weaselly
bastard you should still write thank-you
notes
because it makes you so rare that when
someone gets a thank-you note they will
remember you right it seems like the
only place that thank-you notes are
really taken seriously anymore is when
people interviewing for jobs they now
sometimes write thank-you notes to the
recruiters which I guess shows a sign of
desperation on the part of the recent
graduates but thank-you notes are a
wonderful thing and I would encourage
all of you to go out and buy a stack at
your local dime store and have them on
your desk so that when the moment seizes
you it's right there and I leave my
thank-you notes out on the desk readily
accessible and as I've said before
gratitude is something can go beyond
cards when I got tenure here I took my
whole research team down to Disneyworld
on my nickel for a week and I just I
believe in large gestures but you know
it's also a lot of fun I wanted to go to
write I didn't send them without proper
chaperoning after all what else I have a
paper recycling bin and this is very
good because it helps save the planet
but it also helps save my butt so when I
have a piece of paper that I would be
throwing away I put it in that bin and
that takes I don't know a couple of
weeks to to get filled up and then
actually send somewhere else and so what
I've really done here is I've created
sort of the Windows Macintosh
trashcan you can pull stuff back out of
it works in the real world too
and about once a month I go ferreting
through there to find the receipt that I
didn't think I'd ever need again that I
suddenly need and it's extremely handy I
suspect that if I were giving this talk
in 10 years I would say I just put it in
the auto scanner right because I find it
almost inconceivable that 10 years from
now first off that a lot of the stuff
would be paper in my hands anyway but if
it were paper that I would have any
notion of doing anything other than
putting it on the desk where it goes it
and it's already scanned because it
touched the desk right you know this
kind of stuff is not really hard to do
so I think that's what's going to happen
and of course I have a phone book
notepad I can't live without post-it
notes all right I mean
and the view out the window of the dog
because the dog reminds me that I should
be out playing with him we have we had
the when I got married I married into a
family I got a wife and two beautiful
dogs there's the other one could you
help me with the debate I've had with my
wife by show of hands how many people
would semantically say the dog is on the
couch
nobody thank you thank you because the
dog was not allowed on the couch and my
wife came in one day and anyway thank
you for agreeing with me it makes me
feel very good so the dog is wonderful
the dogs have long gone on but they are
still in our hearts and our memories and
and I think of them every day
and they're they're just they're still a
part of my life
I've presented to you how I do my office
how I do things it's not the only way
one of the best assistants I've ever met
was a woman named Tina Cobb and she has
a really different system she's a
spreader all right if you think about it
there's a method to her madness
everything here is exactly one arms
radius from where she sits you know it's
it's like a two-armed octopus and she
got so much stuff done and I never
presumed to tell somebody else how to
change their system if their system is
working tina was much more efficient
than i was so you know i would just say
look do what works for you and everybody
has to find the system for themselves
but you really got to think about what
makes me more efficient now let's talk
about office logistics in most office
settings people come into each other's
offices and proceed to suck the life out
of each other
if you have a big cushy chair in your
office you might as well just slather
butter all over yourself and send
yourself naked into the woods for the
wild animals to attack you I say make
your office comfortable for you and
optionally comfortable for others
so no comfy chairs I used to have
folding chairs in my office
fold it up against the wall so people
want to come in to me and talk with me
they can stand and I would stand up
because then the meetings going to be
really fast because we want to sit down
but then if it looks like it's something
we should have a little more time on I
very graciously go over and open the
folding chair I'm such a gentleman some
people do a different tack on this they
have the chair already there but they
cut two inches off the front leg so the
whole time you're in their office you're
sort of scooting yourself up I'm not
advocating that but I thought it was
damn clever the first time I saw it
scheduling yourself verbs are important
you do not find time for important
things you make it and you make time by
electing not to do something else
there's a term from economics that
everybody should hold near and dear to
that heart and that term is opportunity
cost the bad thing about doing something
that isn't very valuable it's not that
it's a bad thing to have done it the
problem is that once you spend an hour
doing it that's an hour you can never
again spend in any other way and that's
important now how do you keep these
unimportant things from sucking into
your life you learn to say no it's great
my my youngest child Chloe is at an age
where this is her new word about two
weeks ago she learned it and it's like
now everything's no no no no no no she
should be giving this talk and I asked
her and she said no
so she's how I'm playing all right but
we all hate to say no because people ask
us for help and we want to be gracious
so let me teach you some gentle nose the
first one is I'll do it if I'm really
strapped but I want to help you I don't
want you to be in the bind so if nobody
else steps forward I will do this for
you all right
or I'll be your deep fallback but you
have to keep searching for somebody else
now you will find out about the person's
character at that moment because if they
say great I got my sucker and they
stopped looking then they have abused a
relationship but if they say that's
great my stress level is down at zero
because now I know it's not going to be
a disaster but I'm going to keep looking
for somebody for whom it's less of an
imposition
that's a person that will get lots of
this sort of support okay when I was in
graduate school we did a moving party
with four people a lot of moving parties
carry heavy objects we had four people
we should have had 12 it was a long day
and after that I stopped there new
policy I said from now on when somebody
says will you help me move I'll say how
much stuff you got and they would tell
me I'd say whom that sounds like about
eight people if you give me the names of
seven other people that will be there
I'll be there and I never again was at a
moving party that went for 14 hours in
January in Pittsburgh everybody has good
and bad times a big thing about time
management is find your creative time
and defend it ruthlessly spend it alone
maybe at home if you have to but defend
it ruthlessly the other thing is find
your dead time schedule meetings phone
calls exercise mundane stuff but do
stuff during that where you don't need
to be at your best and we all have these
times and the times are not at all
intuitive I discovered that my most
productive time was between 10:00 p.m.
and midnight which is really weird but
it's sort of this for me it's just this
burst of energy right before the end
let's talk about interruptions an
interruption there are people who
measure this kind of stuff who have stop
watches and clipboards and what they say
is that an interruption takes typically
six to nine minutes but then there's a
four to five minute recovery to get your
head back into what you're doing and if
you're doing something like software
creation you may never get your head
back there the cost can be infinity but
if you do the math on that five
interruptions blows a whole hour so
you've got to find ways to reduce both
the frequency and the length of these
interruptions one of my favorites is
turn phone calls into email if you phone
my office at Carnegie Mellon it says hi
this is Randy please send me email again
I presume everybody here has email how
many people here when a new message
comes in does your computer go ding or
make some other noise we still have
people doing that what the heck is wrong
with you people and I love the fact that
computer scientists just know nothing
about anything so for years by default
all these packages out of the box would
go ding every time you get a new piece
of email so we had taken a technology
explicitly designed to reduce
interruption and we'd turn them into
interruptions
so you just got to turn that off whole
point of email is you go to it when
you're ready not you're sitting around
like Pavlov's dog saying oh maybe I'll
get another email in the same way you
try to not interrupt other people I save
stuff up so I have boxes for Tina or for
my research group meeting and I put
stuff in those boxes and then once a
week or however often when the box gets
full I walk down the hall and I
interrupt that person one time and say
here are the eight things I have for you
how do you cut things short because
people always want to spend more time
than you want to spend you can say look
somebody interrupts you and says you
know got a few minutes and say well I'm
in the middle of something right now and
that tells them I'm interrupting it I'm
going to do it quickly but I got to get
back to that or you can say I only have
5 minutes the great thing about that is
that later you have the privilege of
extending that if you so choose but when
the five minutes are up you can say well
I said at the beginning I had five
minutes and I really have to go now so
it's a very socially polite way to bound
the amount of time on the interaction if
somebody's in your office and they don't
get it now I'm not saying it as a
computer scientist I have an inordinate
amount of time to interact the
opportunity to interact with people with
no social skills
mm but if you have someone in your
office who is just not getting it what
you do is you stand up you walk to the
door you complement them for some reason
this is a crucial part of the process
you thank them and you shake their hand
and if they still don't leave which is
pretty much a guarantee that you're
dealing with someone from my tribe then
you're in the doorway you just keep
going what I have found is that people
don't like it when you look at your
watch while you're talking with them so
what I do is I put a wall on the clock
right behind them so it's just off axis
from their eyes and I can just kind of
glance over a little bit when I need to
see what time it is it's a very nice way
to get me information without being rude
to them time Journal's time is the
commodity you better find out where your
time is going so monitor yourself and
update it throughout the day you can't
wait till the end of the day and say
what was I doing at 10:30 because our
memories aren't that good so what you do
and I really hope that technology within
you know another five years or so will
be so good that the time journals can be
created automatically or at least some
facsimile of it but until then what we
do is we monitor it ourselves so this is
what an empty time journal would look
like the details aren't important but
the key thing is that when you fill it
in you've got a bunch of categories and
what I was doing and you can do this
very informally but you get a lot of
real data about where your time went and
it's always very different anybody who's
done monetary budgeting you look at me
go wow I didn't know I was spending that
much on dry-cleaning or restaurants
would it's always a fascinating surprise
and you always spend more than you think
but with time budgets you find out that
the time is just going wildly
differently than you would have imagined
the best example of this I know is a
Turing Award winner Fred Brooks is time
clocks he's a brilliant computer
scientist but he also has this great
array of clocks in his office and when
you go in and talk to him he says is
this meeting about research or teaching
or whatever and then he flips the
appropriate switch at the end of the
week he knows exactly where his time
went
a man is a genius when when I meet with
students and this is I think Jetts it's
appropriate for people in the workplace
I say what's your schedule you have a
set of fixed meetings every every time
every week and what you have to do is
you have to look at those and identify
the the open blocks where you're going
to waste time and I can tell your waste
time just by looking at it so in this
case you've got a class where you've got
a class at a certain point and then
you've got a gap until the next class so
I've identified those here and the gaps
between classes that in this case lasts
an hour or an hour and a half this is
just prime time to be wasted so what I
always taught my students was make up a
fake class the fake class is go to one
specific place in the library during
that hour and when you're sitting there
with just you in the library and your
books there's a pretty good chance you
might actually study so don't go and
hang out with friends for an hour just
make that a fake class make your own
little study hall it's a simple trick
but it's amazing how effective it is
when somebody just explicitly does it
when you've got your time Journal data
what do you figure out from that what am
i doing that doesn't need to be done
what can someone else do I love everyday
sort of saying what am I doing that I
could delegate to somebody else
my sister is again laughing because she
knows who that person was in our youth
what can I do more efficiently and how
am I wasting other people's time when
you get good at time management you
realize that it's a collaborative thing
I want to make everybody more efficient
it's not a selfish thing it's not me
against you it's how do we all
collectively get more done as you push
on the time journal stuff you start to
find that you don't make yourself more
efficient at work so you can become some
sort of uber worker person you become
more efficient at works so you can leave
at 5:00 and go home and be with the
people that you love people call this
work-life balance for the junior faculty
you may have heard of it in some sort of
mythical sense but it is it is possible
I found that I worked less I work fewer
hours after I got married and I got more
done and I was always fascinated in
graduate school that the people who
graduated
with their PhDs were the people who had
a spouse and kids so how can that be
that's like a built in boat anger
alright
you know you got all these other demands
on your time and I'm like a single guy
and I got all the time in the world and
that's the problem I approach it like I
got all the time in the world so my time
isn't precious when you've got a spouse
and little kids your spouse is likely to
say things to you like you better not be
in at that grad school more than 40
hours a week so when you come in you're
not sitting around playing computer
games not that I ever did that but when
you come in you're coming in and you're
doing work and I found like most people
that once I got married and had kids my
whole view of time management really got
I mean we were playing for real stakes
now because now there are people whose
lives are impacted if I'm spending too
much time at work the other thing about
time management it makes you really
start to look through a crystalline lens
and figure out what's important and
what's not I love this picture I've
blanked out her name but this says blah
blah blah blah blah
words as a pregnant woman and it says
she is worrying about the effect on her
unborn child from the sound of
jackhammers so they're doing
construction and the people here are
laughing because they can see that this
woman who's so concerned about the
jackhammers affecting her unborn child
is holding a lit cigarette you got to
get really good at saying I got to focus
my time and energy on the things that
matter and not worry about the things
that don't know I'm not a medical doctor
and I don't play one on TV but I'm
willing to bet that if I were the fetus
I'd be saying put the cigarette out mom
I can deal with the noise alrighty so in
terms of I want to take a little story
about effective versus efficient I
actually was going to give this talk a
couple of weeks ago and I talked with
game about it and we were going to come
up here because as a surprise for my
wife her favorite musical group in the
whole world is the police and has been
for a long long time
they're a wonderful group and so we said
hey we're going to drive up to
Charlottesville and see them we managed
to get some tickets and I said well
honey well as long as we're up there I
promise Gabe a long time ago I wanted to
give my time management talk and she
said okay because it's about a
three-hour drive so it's very efficient
to couple these two trips together and
about two days later she said you know
honey I know how you are with talks and
before you give one for a couple of days
you start to
and and as we talked through it she said
so we're going to go up in this couples
time away we got a sitter to watch the
kids and this couples time away is going
to be eaten up by you obsessing over
preparing this talk and I thought about
it I said okay so obviously the right
solution is we should keep our couples
time our couples time we'll go up we'll
see the concert you know we'll have our
time together and I'll just schedule a
different day and I'll go up on a one
day trip and I'll do the talk and she
said wow that was easy
and I write once you frame it in the
right way and you say yeah the cost here
is that I have to do the drive a second
time but it turns out I'm doing the
drive with my nephew Christopher and we
talked and my mom was turns out so the
time wasn't even dead time so there was
no loss at all but the key thing was we
said it's not about efficiency it's
about effectiveness and best overall
outcome and of course one of the nice
things was that we did get to go to the
police concert and I really want to
thank gaben and Jim mailer because we
really went to the concert and my wife
was very happy I'm the guy in the back
saying she's not paying any attention to
me today but it but it was wonderful and
he is a charming gentleman in person he
is absolutely charming
so let's talk about procrastination
there's an old saying procrastination is
the thief of time procrastination is
hard and I have a little bit of an
insight here for you we don't usually
procrastinate because we're lazy
sometimes people rationalize their
procrastination they say well gee if I
wait long enough maybe I won't have to
do it right that's true sometimes you
get lucky all right but and other people
say gee if I start on it now I'm just
going to spend all the time on it if I
only if I only give myself the last two
days I'll do it in two days because
that's the work expands to fill the time
available Parkinson's law that's
marginally true but I think the key
balance here is to understand that doing
things at the last minute is really
expensive and it's just much more
expensive than doing it just before the
last minute so if you're doing something
and you can still mail it through the
u.s. mail you have suddenly avoided that
oh my god I've got to do the whole fax
thing now I love FedEx FedEx supports
our whole
Universal habit of procrastination but
it also allows us to get stuff there
when it really has to be there in a
hurry so that's a wonderful thing but I
think you have to you have to realize
that if you push things right up to the
deadline that's where all the stress
comes from because now you can't reach
people if somebody is out of the office
for just one day your whole plan is
upset so you really have to work hard on
this kind of stuff the other things that
deadlines are really important we are
all essentially deadlines driven so if
you have something that isn't due for a
long time
make up a fake deadline and act like
it's real and that's wonderful because
those are the deadlines when push comes
to shove you can slip them by a couple
of days and it's alright
so they're less stressful if you are
procrastinating you've got to find some
way to get back into your comfort zone
identify why you're not enthusiastic
whenever I procrastinate on something
there's always a deep psychological
reason usually it's I'm afraid of being
embarrassed because I don't think I'll
do it well or I'm afraid I'm going to
fail at it and sometimes it involves
asking somebody for something and one of
the most magical things I've learned in
my life is that sometimes you just have
to ask and wonderful things happen but
you just have to you know step out and
do that I I won the parent lottery I
have just wonderful parents and my dad
unfortunately passed away not too long
ago but there's one of my favorite
photographs because my dad was such a
smart guy I could almost never surprise
him or impress him
because he was just that good but we
were down on a family vacation at Disney
World and the monorail were going by and
we're going to board the monorail and we
noticed that in the in the front up here
in the cabin on earth you can see in
this picture but there's an engineer who
drives the monorail and there actually
guessed something there with him which
is kind of unusual my dad and I were
talking about that and I knew because
I've done some consulting for Disney my
dad saying oh they probably have to be
special VIPs or something I thought I
said oh there is a trick there is a
special way you get into that cabin and
he said really what is it I said I'll
show you Dylan come with me and Dylan
who's who's the back of his head you can
see there we walk up and I whispered to
Dylan ask the man if we can ride in the
front and we go to the attendant in the
attendant says why yes you can and he
opens the gate and my dad is just like
I said I told you there was a trick I
didn't say it was hard and sometimes all
you have to do is ask and it's that easy
let's talk about delegation nobody
operates individually anymore and you
can accomplish a lot more when you have
help however most people delegate very
poorly they treat delegation is dumping
I don't have time to do this you take
care of it you know and then they
micromanage and it's just a disaster the
first thing if you're going to delegate
something to a subordinate is you grant
them authority with responsibility you
don't tell somebody go take care of this
but if you need to spend any money
you've got to come back to me for
approval ah that's not empowering them
that's telling them you don't trust them
if I trust you enough to do the work I
trust you enough to give you the
resources and the budget and the time
and whatever else you need to get it
done you give them the whole package the
other thing is delegate but always do
the ugliest job yourself so when we need
to vacuum the lab before a demo I bring
in the vacuum cleaner and I vacuum it
alright do the dirtiest job yourself so
it's very clear that you're willing to
still get the dirt on your hands treat
your people well people are the greatest
resource and if you are fortunate enough
to have people who report to you treat
them with dignity respect and you know
to sound a little bit corny the kind of
love that they should have from someone
who cares about them in their
professional development and for crying
out loud staff and secretaries are your
lifeline all right if you don't think
you should treat them well because it's
a decent thing to do at least treat them
well because if you don't they will get
you right and they will get you good and
you will deserve it and I will applaud
them by giving a talk on time management
with Alf Weaver in the audience where is
elf there he is that's like talking
about surviving the Jonestown flood if
Noah's in the audience one of things
that Alf Weaver taught me is whether
it's to a colleague or to a subordinate
if you want to get something done you
cannot be vague and he said you give
somebody a specific thing to do a
specific date and time Thursday is not a
specific time Thursday at 3:22 gets
somebody's attention and you give them a
specific penalty or reward that will
happen if that deadline for that thing
is not met
and then he paused he said and remember
the penalty reward has to be for them
not you right I won't be screwed over if
you meet that deadline Oh
bummer right this is an important point
to not get wrong challenge people I've
been told that one of the tricks is you
delegate until they complain I don't
know buddy till they complain but what I
found is that under delegation is a
problem people are usually yearning for
the opportunity to do more they want to
be challenged they want to prove to you
and themselves they can be more capable
so let them communication has to be
clear so many times people get upset
with their bosses because there's a
misunderstanding and particularly in a
time of email it's so easy to
communicate via email even if you've had
a face-to-face conversation send a
two-line email just to be specific
afterwards and it's not like we're
trying to be all lawyer like it's just
that as judge Wapner said get it in
writing if you remember the People's
Court and judge Wapner said if there
isn't a problem it's not a problem it
didn't take you much time but if there
ever is a problem well wait a second
there won't be a problem because there's
a written record and that's the magic
there won't be a confusion because you
can't disagree about the written word
don't give people how you want them do
it tell them what you want them to do
give them objectives not procedures let
them surprise you with a way of solving
a problem you would never have imagined
sometimes those solutions are mind
blowing good or bad but they're really
much more fun than just having them do
it the way you would have done it and
you know what if you're in a university
your job should be to have people
smarter than you
ie your students and they will come up
with stuff you would never have thought
of the other thing is tell people the
relative importance of each task I mean
so many people say oh my boss is an ogre
they gave me five things to do I'm like
what do they tell you which one was the
most important oh yeah mmm I guess I
could ask that knowing that if you have
five things which are the ones to get
done is really important because if
you're flying blind you've got a 20
percent chance of getting them done in
the right order and delegation can never
be done to you
does everyone see the difference in the
two pictures this is my daughter Chloe I
love her to death but I want her to grow
up to be a wonderful person and I know
the sooner she holds her own bottle the
better sociology beware upward
delegation sometimes you try to delegate
and people try to hand it back to you
one of the best things I ever saw was
someone who had a secretary trying to
say I can't do this you'll have to take
it back and he just put his hands behind
his back and took a step backwards and
then he waited and then eventually the
secretary said or maybe I could find
this other solution and he said that's
wonderful I'm so proud you thought of
that right it was just it was an elegant
gesture reinforced behavior won't repeat
in one of my favorite stories in the one
minute manager as he talked about did
you ever wonder how they got the killer
whales to jump through the hoop if they
did it like modern American office
managers they would yell at the killer
whale jump through the hoop and every
time the killer whale didn't jump
through the hoop they'd hit it with a
stick right I mean this is how we train
people in the office place read the book
if you want to see how they actually do
it because I'm curious I know now but
it's really cool how they do get them to
do it
so reinforced behavior one repeated when
people do things that you like praise
them and thank them that's worth more
than any amount of monetary reward or a
little plaque people really like to just
be told straight up thank you I really
appreciate that you did a good job the
other thing is that if you don't want
things delegated back up to you don't
learn how to do them I take great pride
I don't know how to run photo copiers
and fax machines and I ain't going to
learn that's certainly now I'm not going
to spend my remaining time meetings the
average executive spends more than 40%
of his or her time in a meeting my
advice is when you have a meeting lock
the door unplug the phone and take
everybody's BlackBerry's because if it's
worth our time it's worth our time if
it's not worth our time it's not worth
our time but I don't have any interest
in being in a room with six people who
are all half there because that's very
inefficient
I don't think meeting should ever last
more than an hour with very rare
exception and I think that there should
be an agenda I got into a great habit a
couple years ago and I just started
saying it's a no agenda I won't
and the great thing about that is
whoever called the meeting had to
actually think before they showed up
about why we were supposed to be there
because otherwise it's like well why are
we here because we had a meeting it's on
all of our calendars it's it's just a
classic Dilbert moment so most important
thing about meetings and again this this
comes from the one minute manager
one minute minutes at the end of a
meeting somebody has to have been
assigned to the scribe and they write
down in one minute or less what
decisions got made and who is
responsible for what by when and then
they email it out to everybody because
if you don't do that you have your next
weekly meeting next week and you all sit
around going now who is going to do this
right it's very inefficient and it's so
fast to just do these one-minute minutes
let's talk about technology people I'm a
computer scientist so they say which
gadget will make me more time efficient
and I don't have an answer for that it's
all idiosyncratic but I will tell you
that my favorite comment about
technology comes from a janitor at the
University of Central Florida who said
computers are faster they just take
longer that's Zen right there so that's
another way of saying only use
technology that's worth it and worth it
is end to end did it make me more
efficient and that depends on how you
work and we're all different and
remember that technology is getting
insane I walked into McDonald's and I
ordered you know happy meal number two
and they said would you like a cell
phone with that I went to the grocery
store to buy 16 slices of American
cheese and you get growl yours
encyclopedia so with 16 slices of cheese
you get all of man's knowledge for free
that's just spooky scary and remember
that technology really has to be
something that makes your life better
you guys may have seen this I just find
it very humorous
so only use technology that helps you I
find the technology is good if it allows
you to do things in a new way just doing
the same things a little bit faster with
technology is nice but when technology
changes the workflow so I was carving
pumpkins a few years ago and this is FM
a good friend of mine and you don't know
if you can see it but down by her right
knee is a pattern and you lay this
pattern over the pumpkin and get this
little special carving knife and you can
instead of these amateurish pumpkins
like I made you get this sort of howling
at the moon and her husband Jeff and I
thought this was really cool but inside
of a reactionary Burning Man kind of a
moment we grabbed our power drills and
we carved our pumpkins that way use
technology if it changes the way you do
things because you get and believe me
the results of a power drill you get
these little oh it's just gorgeous let's
talk briefly about email because email
is such a large part of all our lives
first off don't ever delete any of it
save all of it I started doing this 10
years ago all right an interesting thing
is that all the historians talk about oh
it's such a shame we don't have people
keeping Diaries we don't know what their
day is like I'm like you fools we have
just entered a society circa about ten
years ago and I'm a living example of it
every piece of my correspondence is not
only saved it's searchable so if I were
you know a person of merit a historian
which is a big stretch the historian
could actually look at my patterns of
communication much better than the most
compulsive diary writer now we could
talk about whether or not I'm being in
for full you know introspective that's
that's about content but in terms of
quantity it's great and of course you
can save your email and you can search
it and it's just wonderful because you
can pull back stuff from five years ago
so never delete your email here's a big
email trick if you want to get something
done do not send the email to five
people hey could somebody take care of
this every one of those five recipients
is thinking one and only one thing I
deleted it first
all right so the other four people will
take care of this I don't have to so you
send it to one and only one person but
if you really want it to be done send it
to somebody who can do it tell them
what's again Alf Weaver specific things
specific time and then these the penalty
can be more subtle like you just see see
there boss alright and the other thing
I've had to teach I had this
conversation with every student in my
entire career because they send email
and then they just wait for the person
to respond and I say if the person is
not responded within 48 hours it's okay
to nag them and the reason it's okay to
nag them because if they haven't
responded within 48 hours the chance
that they are ever going to respond is
zero what I mean maybe not zero
maybe that small but in my experience if
people don't respond you within 48 hours
you'll probably never hear from them so
just start nagging them let's talk about
the care and feeding of bosses there's a
phrase managing from beneath because we
all know that all bosses are idiots
that's certainly the expression you know
the offense the sense I've gotten from
everybody who has a boss when you have a
boss write things down and do that clear
communication thing ask them when is our
next meeting what do you want me to have
done by then so you've got sort of a
contract who can I turn to for help
besides you because I want to bother you
and remember your boss wants a result
not an excuse general advice on
vacations phone callers should get two
options the first one is when you're on
vacation the first option is contact
John Smith not me I'm out of the office
but this person can help you now if it's
urgent or call back when I'm back why
because you don't want to come back to a
long sequence of phone messages saying
you know hey Randy can you help me get
care of this and you call him back and
you know you've been on vacation for a
week they already solved it and the
other thing is that it's not a vacation
if you're reading email all right trust
me on that it's not a vacation if you're
reading email I can stay in my house all
weekend and not read email and it's a
vacation
but if I go to Hawaii and I've got a
blackberry I'm not on vacation and I
know this when I got married my wife and
I got married we left our reception in a
hot-air balloon which did not have
wireless on it and
Dean Jim Morris at the time we took a
month-long honeymoon which was great but
not really long enough and Jim Morris
said and I said I'm not going to be
reachable for a month and Jim said
that's not acceptable so what do you
mean it's not acceptable he said well I
pay you so that's the not acceptable and
I said oh okay there and I said there so
there has to be a way to reach me he
said yes I said okay so if you called my
office there would be a phone answering
machine message that said hi this is
Randy I'm on vacation
I waited till 39 to get married and so
we're going for a month and I hope you
have a problem with that but apparently
my boss does so he says I have to be
reachable so here's how you can reach me
my wife's parents live in blah blah blah
town here's their names if you call
directory assistance you can get their
number and then if you can convince my
new in-laws that your emergency merits
interrupting their only daughter's
honeymoon they have our number here's
some of my most important advice we
close with some of the best stuff kill
your television people who study this
say the average American watches 28
hours of television a week that's almost
3/4 of a full-time job so if you really
want to get time back in your life you
don't have to kill your television but
just unplug it put it in the closet and
put a blanket over it see how long it
takes you to get the shakes turn money
into time especially junior faculty
members or other people who have young
children this is the time to throw money
at the problem
hire somebody else to mow your lawn do
whatever you need to do but exchange
time for exchange money for time at
every opportunity when you have very
young children because you just don't
have enough time it's just too hard and
the other thing is eat and sleep and
exercise above all else you always have
time to sleep because if you get
sleep-deprived
everything falls apart other general
advice never break a promise but
renegotiate them if need be if you've
said I'll have this done by Tuesday at
noon you can call the person on Friday
and say I'm still good to my word but
I'm really jacked up and I'm going to
have to stay and work over the weekend
to meet that Tuesday deadline is there
any way there's any slack on that and a
lot of times they'll say Thursdays
fine because I really need it Thursday
but I told you Tuesday or they'll say oh
it's no problem I can have Jim do that
instead of you he has some free time now
if they say no I there's no wiggle room
here you say that's okay no problem I'm
still good to my work all right if you
haven't got time to write it do it right
you don't have time to do it wrong
that's self-evident recognize that most
things are pass/fail people spend way
too much time there's a reason we have
the expression good enough it's because
the thing is good enough and the last
thing is get feedbacks loops ask people
in confidence because if someone will
tell you what you're doing right or
doing wrong and they'll tell you the
truth that's worth more than anything
else in the whole world I recommend
these two books time management is not a
late-breaking field both these books are
old books but I recommend them highly
and it's traditional to close a talk
like with this like this with here's the
things I told you about I'm not going to
tell you the things I told you about I'm
going to tell you the things that you
can operationally go out and do today
first thing if you don't have a day
timer or a personal digital assistant
you know a Palm Pilot or ever go get one
put your to-do list in priority order
you can use the four quadrants or do
what I do just put a number zero 9 but
sorted by priority and do a time journal
if that's really too much effort just
count the number of hours you watch of
television in the next week that's my
gift to you and the last thing is once
you've got your day-timer make a note
for 30 days from today it's okay if that
one goes ding to remind you and revisit
this talk in 30 days it'll be up on the
web courtesy of Gabe and ask what have I
changed and if I haven't changed
anything then we still had a pleasant
hour together if you have changed things
then you'll probably have a lot more
time to spend with the ones you love and
that's important time is all we have and
you may find one day you have less than
you think
thank you
you